so identity is you asking the questions
until eventually you get to a point that
you get to the deeper part of who do you
want to be what life do you want to live
and why do you want to live this life
why is it important why is it what
you're putting through all these hours
why would you want to do that that's
transition when you go through it and
then the pressure part when you said
here so I'm going to be where you
declare your intentions to the world
this is what I'm going to be doing a lot
of times we keep things to secret and so
there's a debate some say you should
never declare your intentions to the
world because that pressure could create
anxiety you should never do it you know
like Babe Ruth pointed a finger and I'm
gonna hit a home run what if you don't
hit it what if you fail you know what if
you say Michael Jordan says the Bulls
never winning losing game seven you
should never say that because there's
too much pressure on the players or then
the other side said well you should put
the pressure on yourself because your
teammates play better because it's not
on them it's on you and the leader does
that to me
um I think declaring intention serves a
purpose I think when you go out there
and you say this is what I'm going to be
doing this is where I'm going to be at
you officially have the world holding
you accountable that pressure could be
good pressure to put into your life we
we hear the phrase peer pressure
and we always get the negative
connotation with peer pressure right
it's like hey don't do drugs because of
peer pressure you know say no to drugs
peer pressure go to school peer pressure
peer pressure where I mean it all
depends what a peer is that's giving you
pressure because if you get the right
peer giving you the right kind of
pressure you can do some big things in
your life so I think that additional
kind of peer pressure you put into
yourself you're in the right circles
right environments those two guys that
you know put some kind of a peer
pressure or Direction into you can
really be a spark to change someone's
life where all of a sudden the identity
goes from being a regular person to the
next day no one recognizes them
in the world of social media of
influencers there's some that will say
things like listen you have a lot of
time take your time you're okay you're
going to be all right you're going to be
fine you have a lot of time and that's
fine that can work for some audiences
and sometimes you wonder if it's almost
like a strategy so other people don't
catch up to you because they think
they're like honestly you sit there and
say is this guy really that dark that
he's trying to get everybody else to
slow down so he kind of you know works
his ass up but hey everybody else you
slow down it's okay where for me on the
other side is listen this never lies
this Lies when I look at my hand this
way I'm 25 years old when I look at my
hand this way I'm 40 years old we look
at our hands too often this way I like
to look at my hands like this this
doesn't lie this is a 40 year old
wrinkles This is 40 okay I can't lie
about that that's 40 years old now I can
look at this and say no I'm a lot
younger I got a lot of time we don't so
for me
I would sit there one of my biggest
drivers was you're at your dad's funeral
this this sounds crazy to some people
but I have visualized it's gonna be the
first time my dad's are going to hear
this because I've never said this to him
because you know I just don't want to
tell them this kind of stuff because I
don't want him to think about it like I
don't want him to say hey I can't
believe you said this I have visualized
my dad's funeral
50 000 times
and when I visualize I'm like okay
you're speaking what are you saying you
know you're at a closing speaker what
are you going to say you okay with it
are you okay with who's going to be
there you know are you okay if he does
at this stage your kids never met him
they don't have a relationship with
Grandpa like you don't for you it
matters because David last name you're
the only person I can continue this
David last name all the other guys
didn't have kids you have to continue
this generation there's a legacy Syrian
Community is a small community we're
endangered species it's not like there's
millions of us it's a very small
community of Syria we lost our country
so I go there and I'm like oh my gosh
that's not how it's going to be here's
how it's going to be he's going to live
this this is what's going to take place
so when that day comes I'm not going to
have any regrets because I'm going to be
good that visualization of going there
creates so much urgency for me that
makes me move too often this whole gift
that we have like we're not putting that
gift of imagination and visualization in
place and so either we waste it and we
just go into La La Land oh my gosh what
if I have a big house what if my you
know zip code is Beverly Hills but if I
have this big house and what if I could
put the big parties what if I date these
hot girls what if I date the best
looking guy what if I have this what if
I have that that's fine but that's not
deep enough you got to go really deep
really deep with purpose and really deep
with if you don't move what could take
place so again going back to it for me
is for people to sit there and realize
if you really want to move yourself ask
the questions go deeper on what Life
Could Happen both good and bad don't
just say oh all good or all bad tap into
both of them and hopefully that creates
urgency for you to start taking the next
necessary serious steps to grow your
business but the gift of imagination and
visualization is rarely used properly
[Music]